all right guys bang-bang I've got
cherven here I'm super excited to have
this conversation so thanks so much for
doing it of course let's start with your
background you were not born in the
United States and you've got a pretty
cool story about how you came to the US
and eventually got into the technology
and business world so we just kind of
start back from I Ron and how you get to
the US absolutely so I you know I'm a
child of revolution in war I remember
bombs falling in Tehran as a
six-year-old you know the bomb sirens
going off in here anti-aircraft shooting
red streaks in the sky everybody would
go in the basement you know of candles
in the fear in people's eyes my dad had
to escape before us and so that was a
pretty you know hard experience he I
found out years later we were just
talking about our dads and they're just
say that they're the greatest generation
that they're they're so humble about
what they've done and they don't really
talk about it but my dad worked for the
Shah and he was head of radio
intelligent for part of the country and
so he actually made some brave decisions
put foreign language broadcast for
embassies for people to know how to get
out of the country and he saved he saved
lives I found out from people later like
in the last 10 years people coming in
saying you know your dad helped us back
in the day you know in 79 and so on and
so he was put on the execution list by
Khomeini and he had to go underground
and hide and so we didn't see him and
then one night is a good story about
karma which I think a lot about and he
helped a friend of his from his hometown
on the Caspian Sea who was from a poor
family but a religious family the guy
came and he had holes in his shoes and
asked them for for a job for hell
and my dad gave him a job you know with
him and then a couple years later
somebody fired the guy without telling
my dad and my dad found out reinstated
him said you know don't touch this guy
he's my guy and that guy ended up being
head of security for the airport so it's
like out of Argo right so he comes and
he's like you're you know reaches out to
my mom and it's like you're your husband
helped me a lot and I want to help and
she checked with him that it was safe
and then my dad got in touch and they
met at column number four at the airport
and he walked them through security on
the Air France flight to get out of
there before he was going to be killed
so I mean life became very real and
dramatic you know quickly we didn't see
him for two years and then iran-iraq war
it started and then me my mom and
brothers sister got out and that had in
Washington DC and start over we came
with nothing so it's really like a
merican dream story I would we're so
grateful to America we're all American
citizens we love America and we wouldn't
have any opportunity without America and
I think given you know it's very
relevant in terms of you know the
immigrant story and welcoming immigrants
to America who rejuvenate the American
Dream and help build the economy a lot
of the tech companies we know about you
know almost the majority are started by
immigrants and they create a lot of jobs
and had a huge economic impact so know
that that's how we started and they just
my parents really focus on education and
so I just went from English for speakers
of other languages I didn't know any
English and then to get in town it into
a magnet school where I was lucky to you
know get access to things like next
computers and
dad worked overnight shifts and so did
my mom so they can buy me an apple to
see I remember it was my first computer
a little green screen that changed my
life and never looked back and has
always been excited about science and
research and technology and innovation
from since I was a kid yeah and there's
something I think really kind of special
about immigrants that are highly
educated very successful in other
countries and they come to the United
States and I think that you've said in
previous interviews that your father
started off as a cab driver Yeah right
and there's this element of humility
that goes along with I have to start
over or at least rebuild a life and I
always you know laugh and kind of tell
friends Americans discount that but
Americans don't realize there's very few
Americans who would do the opposite
right leave America go somewhere else
and kind of be able to start over again
they don't kind of have some of that
humility and it's an over generalization
there's plenty of people who could do it
but for the most part I think that
that's a discounted part of kind of the
immigrant story is it takes a lot to
swallow your pride and go from you know
the what sounds like high levels of
government and kind of success to
driving a cab right and kind of
rebuilding from scratch you know every
American is an immigrant at some point
right in their in their bloodlines every
one of us came here and you know if you
go back thousands of years Native
Americans came here they migrated here
as well and so you know the American
story is an immigrant story from the
beginning it's a story of immigrants
since the story of bravery and courage
you know and you know wherever you look
at you know the first Americans to
settle or you look at later generations
of Italians and Greeks and Irish and and
everyone that had to come here and
wasn't welcome in some circles there
were signs saying no I
in apply right so you know every
immigrant group Jewish and so on Arab
and so on has had two inversions have to
come here and bootstrap from the
beginning no matter what generation they
came here and I think that's what really
Bond's the American identity everyone
still has that everyone whoever your
family came here two hundred years ago
all right or or five years ago that that
is part of the the ethic of what it
means to be an American so I think that
that's really what unites us more than
divides us and that's why I think
entrepreneurship and I wrote about this
years ago I was in I was in Romania
chasing a really an amazing developer
who had developed a graphic Center for
the iPhone back in like 2008-2009 that
enabled us to do multi game multiplayer
games over 3G Apple hadn't even enabled
that yet and this young guy who'd
figured that out so I flew to Romania
and never been before and met him closed
the deal and we'd launched the most
advanced 3d graphics engine and game on
the iPhone and when I was out there I
wrote about entrepreneurship and I
realized at the time as I met this young
developer did the American story had
become global that entrepreneurship had
become global that Silicon Valley wasn't
a physical place anymore it was a
mentality it was an idea and had gone
viral and I knew at that moment this was
like 2008-2009 I knew at that moment
that the world was going to accelerate
by the energy of that virality of
entrepreneurship that America and the
American story had inspired
and you know and one of the things I
realized is that we could be left behind
right by that momentum if we didn't keep
up and that's where you know
entrepreneurs like Travis or Elon and in
others who are builders as Marc
Andreessen you know rightly talked about
it's time to build this is a time for
builders this is a call to arms for
builders we can re architect rebuild
everything wherever it's our currencies
our financial systems our health systems
or medical systems our government
systems are you know all of the above is
up for grabs
is up for people with talent and ability
and drive and will and passion and love
to like work and and build incredible
things today like as we speak
you know SpaceX is gonna launch the
first astronauts on on their rockets and
that is a momentous a momentous
achievement this is this is a private
company that is now building the bridge
for us to become an interplanetary
species which is eelain's goal and and
that's the ultimate in terms of building
right he's talking about building a
whole new world and you plan it and it
sounds crazy but I would never bet
against you on so you've obviously spent
a good amount of time with him and I
think that one of the pieces that to me
is very obvious is he one is
misunderstood too because he is so
ambitious and believed so deeply that he
and his team can drive so much
innovation it's an easy target to attack
both in the media in private etc maybe
help us understand a little bit as
you've actually spent time with him
what are your takeaways and kind of how
do you evaluate both him as a person but
also to kind of those ambitions across
SpaceX Tesla and then maybe we can get
into some of the Hyperloop stuff after
that yeah well my experience have been
you know incredibly meaningful we've had
some experiences like traveling together
to to hear square - I'm sorry - did you
know he'd saw a trip that I did - to
hear square in the middle of the
revolution and then I went to Libya in
the middle of the revolution same trip
with Sean Penn and we met with the
rebels in Benghazi as they had liberated
like two weeks before Gaddafi was killed
and it was an incredible incredible
experience and he was like you know look
next trip you take like that I want to
go with you and I was like well we're
thinking about going to Cuba and there
was an American who was in prison for
eight years there and we were like you
know maybe we can help with that and so
we're basically doing hostage
negotiations as Ilan likes to tell it
and you know we coordinated coordinated
when in terms of what we were what our
goals were and said you know and also
the idea of like you know bringing
helping to bring internet to tea island
and and we knew that bringing
connectivity and communication to a
country can really open things up and
and so that was the trip and it took six
months to get the approvals and IANS jet
was the second American plane to land in
Cuba in 50 years and so we landed there
and we met with ministers and we met
with University students we you know now
with you know Castro's son like you know
with artists and one of the things we
said was like look you know you've got
to release this American there's nothing
to talk about
if you don't and
within a year they they released them
and and then Obama opened up Cuba and
Rolling Stones came in for a free
concert a half a million people and in
effect it changed right and in that trip
and Ilan said that was his favorite trip
at the time we started talking about on
the plane we started talking about
Hyperloop and I remember you know
everything kind of very clearly and I
remember saying look you know what are
you gonna do with it
you know what this was an idea the paper
wasn't written and what he said was look
you know he's got five boys
SpaceX Tesla Solar City you know he's
super busy and he didn't have time to do
anyone to open source in any way so I
said you know do you mind if I try to
you know create a company around it and
he was like no go ahead and my idea was
I didn't want to just do people
transport I wanted to revolutionize the
idea of logistics cargo and commerce and
the idea was imagine if you could order
something right online and it begins to
be manufactured in real time manufacture
distributed and delivered all within 48
to 72 hours from anywhere in the world
imagine that kind of real-time pulse to
the global economy and and he was like
that's a really good idea and I don't
see any technical reason why you
couldn't do people hadn't cargo so that
was that was a business model and I
started to work on it and one of the
things you you know to Ilan is one he's
an absolute genius - he is incredibly
loyal I mean he's a family person he
loves his family he loves his friend you
know close friends and he's
incredibly loyal to those people into
his teams that are building these these
incredible incredible companies with
them and I saw multiple examples of that
and it was just you know in every
experience there's a reason why people
build great things with leaders and
visionaries like that they are inspired
they're inspired to do something more
with their lives and to contribute
something to the advancement of our
world and you know there's nothing
better than waking up in the morning and
realizing all these years of work that
you're sending to human beings in the
space on a private rocket like come on
how cool is that look if you see the the
kind of hype video if you will that NASA
and SpaceX released today I mean you
watch this thing and you're like again
and I tweeted a couple times so I don't
know how you bet against these people
right you know whether it's Elon whether
it's the SpaceX team whether it's NASA
just the fact that they have worked and
in the part I actually wrote about this
morning was this isn't something they
started working on two years ago right I
mean we're talking to almost 20 years
he's been working on this problem and it
started from a first principle
standpoint I gotta fix this rocket
technology get the cost down I have to
kind of get cargo and then I can get
people and and this is a multi-decade
type body of work that we're just now
starting to see I think where people say
wait they actually may pull this off
right but it's 20 years in the making
yeah I mean I everyone is praying for
the safe journey of the astronauts
that's incredibly important obviously to
their to their families and and to the
movement of humanity expanding beyond
you know our planet and you know I was
telling that story of having a
conversation of Elon in 2012 about
humans going astronauts going on in his
rockets and we were going to the opening
ceremony of the
the Olympics in 2012 and we got stuck in
traffic we were gonna be late and we saw
some bikes for EM so we jumped out of
the car and ran into bikes and bikes and
made it but then my my leg cramped as we
were walking running and he like put his
arms around you know supported me to
walk to a bench and then ran and got
water because I was dehydrated obviously
and we sat down and we talked and I
asked him about you know when he think
humans will go on your rocket and he was
so thoughtful his number-one concern was
the safety of the astronauts that's all
he was concerned about he was projecting
like 2023 I think and he beat that but
but that was his paramount concern
nothing else he wasn't trying to rush to
get there and risk you know anyone's
life and there's always some risk no
matter what you do but it's also an
important reminder that look we put
humans on the moon in the 60s right I
mean wow I mean you know and and Kennedy
got up there and said you know wanting
to put a man on the moon within the
decade and they did it and they did it
with computers with the power of a
calculator today and it's an incredible
achievement but we should also
understand that it wasn't just just an
engineering achievement it was a
financial achievement and decision I
think the numbers I saw once I wrote
about this once about the the actual in
kind of 1960s dollars that they
committed to fund putting a man on the
moon within the decade was something
like 250 billion dollars right and it
was something like four or five percent
of the GDP at the time and that's an
incredible achieve you know a commitment
and achievement and so it's like we
you've already done this we have these
skills a private company hasn't done it
our government or our people did it but
companies have to have that skill as
well and it's another area where where I
talk about companies becoming you know
almost like sovereigns right
I call them many sovereigns and you know
Tim Cook of Apple has the power you know
an Apple has the power and financial
power of a nation-state Amazon and Bezos
same thing Google right and imagine in
the Spacek sample if Elon pulls it off
any colonizes Mars in the next 20 30
years and begins to cede humanity there
which is absolutely his goal again it
sounds crazy but that is his goal and
every crazy idea he's had guess what he
did it from PayPal - you know - SpaceX -
Tesla - Solar City and so on
so like you said I wouldn't bet against
that yeah another founder that you spent
a bunch of time with who I think has
very similar qualities is obviously
Travis and uber maybe tell the story of
when did you first meet Travis and kind
of when did you become aware of uber as
a company and sort of looking at it yeah
I got I became aware of hoover super
early when it had launched and i was a
fan and i was trying to get in touch
with try didn't know i'm at the time so
this was probably like 2010 ish and it
coincided with me becoming a venture
capitalist for the first time so that
that opportunity came to me in like i
started June June 2 2011 and I chased
over in a number of other companies that
I thought were going to be massive
companies like Airbnb and others
and Travis was notoriously hard to get
in touch with he wasn't going to answer
some VC's email right so I had to and he
said this and uh you know he said this
before he was like I had to I had to
respond to serve him because I basically
had everyone in his network who I knew
and knew well vouch for me so they
started saying than him like hey you
should talk to serve and and I'm talking
about swarming not not not like one
person a to person like and you know it
was everyone from like Julius
Genachowski who is later the head of the
FCC you know - drew drew Houston from
Dropbox - the list goes on and so he did
you know he finally responded and I had
told another friend of mine who was an
investor in uber that you know and on
the board I was like look if if they
ever raised money let me know or decide
to take you know raise money and so he
did me a favor the day of that board
meeting he called me and he said hey you
know we're gonna raise raise a new round
and this is when uber was I think this
was probably August September of 2011
uber is probably doing about 1.8 million
dollars in net revenue had about six or
seven thousand cars drivers on it most
of that was San Francisco and like New
York was like twelve hundred cars like
it was tiny so I started chasing it and
I was in the race I was hustling doing
everything I can to win and I got beat
by another firm that I respect a lot but
I Travis didn't he called me and he was
like hey homie that's exactly what he's
like he was like I really like you I
wanted I wanted to go if you but I have
to go so the firm and I took it real
cool I was
I totally understand because as an
entrepreneur I get it
sometimes you have to make that call and
so I said to him you know
congratulations I'm happy for you I
totally understand if anything goes
wrong and the diligence or anything else
I want you to know that I'm like a
hundred ten thousand percent behind you
so you negotiate with strength because
you've gotta back up and he was like I
appreciate that and that was it and then
I was giving a keynote in like Tunisia
for President Obama's whole
entrepreneurship thing in the Middle
East and I got a call on my cell phone
and it was Travis and luckily the signal
was there I picked up and he was like
hey you know you remember what you told
me I was like yeah he was like is that
still on it was like absolutely
he's like can you meet me in Dublin
there was this founders conference so I
got on the next plane landed hit the
streets of Dublin had a fight with him
in a Irish pub and as we were walking
kind of the cobblestone streets at night
he told me his full vision at that time
and it was I'm not a taxi company I you
know I want to replace car ownership
right and suddenly the tan or the total
addressable market became you know
trillions it wasn't you know and that's
the mistake my competition made is they
were comparing over to a black car
company or a taxi company and those
comps are totally different than a
technology platform marketplace that
could also expand into many other areas
like transportation food and so on and
so that night we agreed on a valuation
was 290 million and people thought we
were crazy you know me and my firm were
crazy for giving that valuation but I
went to his you know I printed it out at
the business center in the hotel went to
knocked at his door and I have a picture
of us signing the term sheet at the door
and we ended up putting you know 26 and
a half million at 290 so about 8% of the
company and it turned out to be a great
investment and Travis and I became very
close I would say one super intelligence
right like Travis you know Elon or in
that category like top 10 that I've met
grit like real grit incredible willpower
just constantly thinking and working and
they're both incredible recruiters
absolutely I mean some of the best
recruiters I've ever seen Travis spends
a lot of time recruiting and you look at
what he did with with uber and then he
look at what he's doing with his current
company in the cloud kitchen space and
he's recruiting like crazy he's you know
and he's building a great company again
and he's right again right he's
absolutely right about the trends and
and he's building a really really
important part of that vision and you
know and that takes that kind of
incredible drive and commitment and so
when you get that phone call you go to
Dublin
how much negotiating is there versus
Travis tell me what you want and we're
in because we believe in you
specifically and you know we have this
kind of deep-seated belief that you're
going to build a successful company and
the terms today don't matter as much
like is it something where you guys are
literally sitting down it's every single
term is getting negotiated or is it more
of you know what I call like the Warren
Buffett deal where he says hey look
basically I know if I'm gonna do you
know multi-billion dollar deal in the
first five minutes on the phone right
and yeah I gotta figure out the details
but but I pretty much know quickly like
how did that actually go down yeah I
think you know the the other firm that
had one initially tried to reprice the
deal which if you know Travis you
don't do that and you know I didn't know
Travis that well but my instinct already
was don't mess with that like you know
if you give your word keep it
and I'm person of my word like if I give
my word I follow through and that's why
also a key part of why we became so
close because we knew like when you're
dealing with someone where there's no
artifice right Elon is exactly the same
way there is no tricks they don't need
to tricks are for people who are have a
reason to do the trick right to get some
advantage but if you work incredibly
hard and you're super intelligent you
don't need to rely on tricks you just
build right and so we bonded because we
knew when we were speaking to each other
there was zero artifice and what we said
we meant it and if we were wrong about
what we believed at the time we were
open to being convinced that we were
wrong and and then move on and I saw
that in him like he might disagree with
you violently you know or I might
disagree violently but in you know after
hashing through all the logic one of us
would come out the other side agreeing
with with the other if we weren't
agreeing in the first place so I think
that's that you know that's part of it
so I think we got lucky to that we were
in that situation where there was that
repricing
so I remember offering to 90 over text
because I went to like work on a term
she talked to my team and and and then
you know I think I thought I'd just come
out with a little bubble thing you know
yeah but so I was like I said it and
then I was waiting for him to respond no
bubble right and you know like oh crap
like I'm like is he negotiating
against me with somebody else you know
or with the same firm using my offer to
like you know get a better deal and but
you know that whole thing about keeping
your word you know luckily he came back
and before he came back I remember I'm
increasing the offer I was like 295
because I got nervous and he was like no
I mean that's that's cool
we'll stick to $2.99 and I think 290 and
you know it was the first time I think
Travis has ever agreed to a lower price
on his own you know so those so we're
over 290 yeah and so what's really
interesting is Travis Ilan there's many
other examples and histories these folks
are all able to go across industries
right obviously Ilan there's
similarities between space launching
electric vehicles Solar City whatever
but the most common aspect of those
three companies is Elon right we look at
Travis with uber cloud kitchens you know
Travis and so how much of these
investments and the building of the
companies is dependent just on who's
driving the company versus picking the
right markets or you know actually
building the right products like you've
invested in so many companies at this
point you know there's the argument that
some people are founder investors some
are market and some are product like
where do you come out on that framework
and what do you actually look for when
you're making these investments yeah I
was telling the story of my daughter
when she was 11 I took her to her
favorite sushi place and she was like
that how do you how do you invest you
know what do you what do you do and and
I looked her and I said you know I call
it the love principle like you have to
love the founder the team the product
the market right and if you don't love
any one of those things probably not a
good investment and she looks up at me
and she's like well I love Great America
and it was true she would go there every
weekend we'd always go for Hollywood
Halloween Haunt and and
and I was like okay so you love Great
America like here's what you have to do
you have to go there and interview and
do what's called diligence interview the
employees get it you know get get
insights and she did that she being back
she's like dad all the employees like
love the company they love the CEO the
company's called Cedar Fair the 49ers
are doing a billion dollar stadium there
and I was like there you go
so Cedar Fair is a public company that's
your first investment so she made a
hundred percent return and she's
starting her own company now 19 and when
she was 18 she started it
and you know she learned a really
important lesson she's using the profits
from that investment that she did which
was 11 to start this company but I tell
that story because that is exactly how
and us like those are the four quadrants
and if I have any kind of you know
qualitative or quantitative reason not
to believe in one of those things I'm
not going to do the investment and for
whatever reason that's been working I'm
up about 73 X since 2011 which is
amazing like I never first of all I
never thought I was going to be a
venture capitalist investor you know I'm
immigrant kid poor kid like I just
didn't I just never I didn't think that
was possible and I was surprised when
that I started getting those you know
offers and and and opportunities and so
that that formula is something you know
that is qualitative and quantitative and
some people are really good at the
quantitative and some people are really
good at the qualitative if your book
good at both I think you can go in the
pantheon of great investors in terms of
track record and also in terms of just
reputation amongst founders I think the
what you said about Elon and Travis is
absolutely right like we look for great
founders right that are building
industries like one of the things I say
is like build industries
don't just build companies and you know
that is a an interesting juxtaposition
in terms of some of the fissures you're
seeing in the venture capital world
versus you know founders founders are
amazing founders have a lot of
opportunity to get funding and also can
be picky and choosey and when you're not
picky and choosey you end up with bad
investors on your board on your cap
table and it is a nightmare
we've lived through things like that and
it can be an absolute nightmare and so
you know if you look at like Elan story
like they were venture capitalists that
when he needed the money in December and
that sixty minutes interview where he
you know had tears talking about that at
that moment where he thought that his
companies were gonna die right that he
had worked so hard and he put every
dollar that he had into those companies
to save them and he was living at his
friend's homes and didn't have a house
and and was basically homeless working
on these companies having put every
dollar that he made on PayPal and and
and his other startup as a mapping
company that he had started in its early
20s and so he took that kind of bold
risk and you know I think a couple of
the VC's especially one bowed out you
know at the last minute and Elon like
had to rescue the company and and I
don't think he ever forgot that right I
don't think he and he never wanted to be
in that position again where his company
could get killed I think Travis is has
gone through similar types of journeys
and you know he's working on his company
I don't think there is a VC on that cap
table right and so I think what's going
to happen is great founders like Travis
and others
are going to fund other great founders
and founders going to become more
careful right if they have the luxury of
choice they're going to be careful about
who and what firms and who what angels
what investors they bring in because if
you bring a psychopath into your company
you know if you bring us you know
someone that schemes against the company
for whatever reason it can kill a
company it can destroy billions of
dollars of value and also hold back
progress for Humanity especially with
these types of founders so it's it's an
interesting branch of investing in
entrepreneurship which is there are that
many of these types of founders right
and I have the thesis that as
entrepreneurship spreads and goes viral
that we're gonna find the e lines of
Africa the travis's of South America
right like we're gonna find the
undiscovered edison's that are out there
that have that talent but opportunity
hasn't come to them because opportunity
wasn't democratized and that's where
we're at now and if you think about the
next 20 years the next 40 years d you
know people say disruption but that
doesn't really cover what's happening
the speed at which these innovations are
coming are getting exponentially faster
look at but you know blockchain and
Bitcoin and and what's happening these
are to me systemic bets long-term
systemic bets on the future of humanity
and when you back someone like Elon or
you you know or you buy an in dust and
Bitcoin these are two different types of
asset classes but they're long-term
systemic bets on the future of humanity
and I'm into systemic bets those are
those are massive bets those are those
are like Tam's
you know
squared you know there did the the
what's a total addressable market of a
planet of a new world of a new
civilization like what right and so if
you think that big and you think
intergenerationally if you think beyond
your own life in terms of your
investments whatever you're investing
for your family institution yourself and
so on you have to think long term and it
strikes me that once you see one or two
of these work you almost become
emboldened right so if you had never
seen SpaceX or Tesla or uber or any of
these companies actually play out you
almost become more risk averse but when
you see them work you then start to
think that way right you get that
feedback loop of they actually want
those market expanding technologies I
want those founders who can think
intergenerationally and so maybe talk a
little bit about like because you have
been so close to some of these founders
who you know will go down as the best
founders of our lifetime right it's kind
of where this is headed and these
companies end up being industry defining
companies how has that changed the types
of companies that you invest in since
you've been close to those people and
those companies that's a great that's a
great question as you were saying asking
a question I was thinking about it
almost as a hundred percent that that
fear is what keeps people fear is what D
risks people's potential right and and
so they in their mind when when when you
make a little bit right I remember when
I remember when I made my first little
bit of liquidity and I called my dad and
then I was like you know it was like you
know his first time ever had any
liquidity and it was like I don't know
about four million dollars and this is
like going from like nothing to like
whoa I just
all the company I got four million
dollars Wow and I had never felt what
[ __ ] you money was until that moment I
couldn't understand it there's no way
you understand until you have it I swear
it it is a liberation of the soul right
and because at that point you can walk
away greatest negotiators have the
leverage to walk away from the
negotiating table right and at the
negotiating table of life if you don't
have that leverage you're trapped and
you're willing to compromise beyond your
comfort levels right but when you have
that [ __ ] you honey it becomes a
liberation point I've called my dad I
was like dad this is what it feels like
I didn't know what that felt like
right and guess what I put every dollar
that I made into Ober right today I was
like that was the right thing to do
because you know that's another 400x on
top you're right like so that was a
right bet but it but I was willing to
kind of risk it all put all the chips on
one thing and it could have gone really
badly but it didn't right and then it's
like oh do I do I risk it again
right do I make that bet again and
that's where someone like Elon that
would took every dollar and put it all
into SpaceX and Tesla and SolarCity that
he didn't have that fear right so the
antidote
the antidote to fear is exactly what
you're talking about is that if you
become attune to the possibility of a
massive bet that you believe in in your
passion about that's when you're willing
to forget your fear it gives you kind of
anybody's right
makes you immune to that fear and if
you're willing to take a big systemic
you know bat it could turn out great and
it has in those cases yeah you you
obviously have been right multiple times
and I've asked chim off
I've asked more Cuban a couple of others
what were you doing when you realize
that you had a billion dollars right so
Mark Cuban said he knew exactly how much
stock yet he was sitting he was just
refreshing and refreshing and he
described it as he went and did a naked
dance right he just could he was so
excited it's a little bit different I
think with the venture capital side
where everything's illiquid and it
doesn't track kind of a stock price so
kind of what was that you know for you
like do you remember what you were doing
and then to mentally you talked about
kind of the unshackling right and you
almost it seems like can enter into a
different mindset of what can I actually
invest in what do I want to spend my
time doing maybe talk a little bit about
going from nothing to four million this
kind of it seems like one level then
going from four million to a billion
plus is a whole nother level and almost
I got another level to the game if you
will the thing I'm proudest of is that
these investments have returned billions
of dollars to a lot of LPS that are
retirement funds of our grandparents and
nonprofits that are doing really good
work in the world
like that like my measure of billions is
not what I'm acquiring but how I'm
contributing to the cycle of giving
right and helping to fund these
incredible institutions and nonprofits
pension funds that are the livelihood of
humanity that you know put bread on the
table of people's you know in people's
homes and so that
me is the most important part and one of
the things I've noticed is none of the
great founders ever really gave a [ __ ]
about money like once you kind of like
like that four million that was the
taste it didn't make a difference it was
four million or a billion or five
hundred million or 300 million or
whatever it happens once it doesn't
matter where ever it was before it's
that moment the mental switch the
unshackling right of your mind and the
opening up to the possibility that you
can do not just a 10x but a hundred x
right and in some cases thousands of X
in terms of impact and one of my good
friends Peter Diamandis
one of the things he talks about is you
know the true billionaire ISM is about
having an impact on a billion people in
a positive one not a negative one and we
see some great founders who build
products that are inherently flawed and
the impact they have on humanity and you
know I love Facebook but I haven't been
on Facebook for five or six years and
you know and we've seen the impact
that's had systemically and I believed
in the early days of like the positive
impact but I think from a policy
perspective you know and now we're going
through similar types of things with
other platforms but we have to get ahead
of those things you have to have manage
there's those products so that you you
continue to have positive impact at
scale how do you think about that
balance for a platform so take Facebook
right I worked there in 2014 and 15 and
there was always this balance I think
even internally of connecting the world
is a you know a great mission right and
there's lots of kind of net positive
aspects of that it doesn't come without
challenges though right and we've seen
that everything from on the election
side and kind of all of that stuff to
other aspects like just
you know terrorist content can get
shared and communication between bad
actors and and all of that and so how do
you think through that balance for
platforms and do you get to a point
where you almost have to accept that
there's some negative impact but it's a
net positive and so we should you know
kind of continue to encourage these or
do you see it as hey we should work
tirelessly to eliminate any negative
impact and only focus on promoting the
the positive aspect like how do you
mentally break that down well I think
part of it is when you're generating
tens of billions of dollars a profit off
a platform like that you become trapped
to the engine of profit right and it
blurs the lines of right and wrong
because you might make a decision that
you know is wrong ethically but is right
for your profits and that's not that's
that's the conundrum and when you're at
that kind of scale where you have a
massive part of humanity on the platform
the impact it can have is it can change
sway elections it can you know lead to
genocides and like you know on violence
and all these things and you know it's
unfortunate because in the beginning the
reason why I went to Egypt in Libya in
the middle of those revolutions is I was
inspired by people like Hemingway who
went to the Spanish Civil War and
actually he fought if I I went to
observe and learn and it was still scary
right and but back then I was like I
wrote essays about this that you know I
said you know the last bastion of
dictatorship is the router all right and
we have to pay you know if if dictators
can control the router they can they can
Bay State that's they can shut off the
internet the mobile which is exactly
what happened in in places like Libya
and an Egypt and but back then the
impact of Twitter and Facebook on those
movements was very positive
so I was an optimist about it and I
think the reason why him off and me and
others have have you know been persuaded
that it's having an overwhelmingly
negative impact is something happen in
between at the back tiny scale where the
the moral compass became blurred and and
and so you know it's it's fixable it's
just a matter of will and sometimes you
know a company has to decide that it has
to fundamentally change some things and
that I mean that I mean short term or
medium term even long term compression
of the profits but overall it will lead
to a healthier ecosystem eventually
within which to continue to scale yeah
and then on these platforms we've seen a
complete rise of what I'll call kind of
a new generation of creators right and
you've tweeted quite a bit about this
what I was called the creator class
right so a number of tweets that you've
had
I just love where you're like look you
know Joe Rogan's a billionaire Kylie's a
billionaire and the this creator class
is some we'll call it new media some
will call it kind of influence or the
influencer economy but but it's
definitely something that wasn't there
in the size scope or mechanism that it
is today even ten years ago right and so
maybe talk a little bit about like what
is drawing your attention to that and
how do you view that creator class kind
of in the world order if you will of
what we're seeing happen yeah great
question I mean I am so I started going
down to LA in like 2008 I had sgm social
game you know it was one of the first
gaming companies social gaming companies
on Facebook platform
and then on the iPhone and you know on
the iPhone where one in four iphones had
one of our games and we merged that
company with a company called mind
joltin that's jam city now so they're
doing it like half a billion on the I in
revenue on the iPhone now and so I was
going down to LA and I was meeting with
people in that world in the
entertainment world and I remember like
back then I was saying like hey bring
loss to the Facebook platform as a
social game and you know it was hard to
convince people to take those kinds of
bets right because of that same
conservative type thinking about
platforms and taking that kind of risk
but it was absolutely the right call to
do right
you know same same pitch on the iPhone
and so on and then when I started
investing I I started talking to friends
of mine down there having these
discussions and I was trying to build
bridges between Silicon Valley and in LA
and some people got in some people were
like I want 20% of the company and I was
like sorry like yeah that's not gonna
happen that's not how it works you've
got to put some money into it you know
invest just like everybody else and help
the company you know you're not getting
20% and so the we help change the
culture down there to an investor class
culture right - you know shareholder
culture versus like I'm me and I deserve
20% so that was important so you know
conversations and meeting people like
you know Jay Brown and jay-z or Troy
Carter or Scooter Braun or you know Adam
Lieber and Ari Emanuel and bringing them
into a burr like those were the ones
that were that got it invested and made
a great return on their investment with
with us into Oberer right and how
the company a lot and and all of that
but then I think the legend of those
investments is what changed the culture
in LA because the people who passed that
I talked to but I won't name right they
they they were kicking themselves
they're like what was I thinking why
didn't I put in that $250,000 I can get
a foreigner next return whatever and you
know ended up being so it's um
that's one then between 2008 and now and
2020 the the evolution it's happened is
that people now the influencer and the
founders and the people have are the
brands are the company and you know
companies can live and die but an
influential person wherever it's a
founder and an entertainer and so on
anyone that has an audience that's loyal
and spends time with them similar to how
you you do or rogen to us and others do
you know have a chance to build
something that impacts billions of
people and makes them billionaires right
and so the power especially in terms of
the new media paradigm is that you know
these influence or influencers who are
also great entrepreneurs can build
incredible value for themselves their
families their employees their teams and
so on and investors faster than in any
other time in history what's driving
that is that a technology inflection
point is that a just mindset people now
are thinking there's a different way to
monetize this or build these companies
or is there something else that's
driving it what's the death of the
middlemen just like the death of the
salesman then the middleman was a
remnant of a different world and all of
the people they were in between these
influencers and the audience and not
just people but companies all of the
agencies and the management companies
and all these other things that were in
the middle taking a cut even the lawyers
in LA get a cut of everything someone
makes it's insanity it's you know a form
of slavery and so you know I'm not gonna
get a lot of love from the lawyers in LA
but I mean it doesn't make when I found
out the lawyers get a percentage like
you know agents are managed and it was
like why pay their fees and move on but
that was the mentality and the culture
which then in turn made people desperate
and overestimating their worth and
saying I want 20% of the company when
it's like no no invest make a great
amazing return and learn how to be a
founder and build your own company so I
think it's not collapse and compression
where the influencer and their audience
became one right like it's that trend
that we just saw where the young lady
created a cult right you know the step
step chickens or whatever it's gone I
think that's hilarious right but it's a
genius move because she realized that if
she could collapse the audience and she
becomes the audience and the audience
becomes her and suddenly she's a
platform and suddenly the audience and
the fans are a platform in unison right
United and look what they did overnight
top of the charts you know you know put
out an app the ranking goes up all the
comments streams of all these inputs are
suddenly same profile picture genius
what it reminds me a lot of is the old
model was let's build a product or a
service and then go spend a bunch of
time money and resources to find the
customers or the audience right so it's
kind of company first audience and
customers second now though that's
inverting right actually was
things people are building the audiences
first and then they're basically going
back to the drawing boards okay I've got
this massive audience of hundreds of
thousands or millions of people what do
I build to serve them
is it a mobile app is it you know a
merchandise store is it some other
product you know kylie jenner or
whatever and to me that almost feels
like if you can build the audience it's
actually a great way to de-risk the
company building right because you know
that there's an audience there and so
you're drastically increasing the
probability of the product market fit in
the future the product market fit is the
is the person the brand is the person
and and let me talk about reducing cap
right the customer acquisition costs if
if you if you have an audience and you
can do what Joe did and went and what
Daniel Act just they're together
you know that's the beginning of the end
of any kind of middlemen in the media
world and we already have experienced
that an attack world where the elands
and Travis's can create you know
incredible world-changing companies on
their own and then back others like them
all right or the the kylie can create a
billion dollar company and she's what 22
23 years old or Kanye can take his
genius and design a shoe and easy and
create a three billion plus company with
his creativity all right
and so I think you know that's that's
the trend it's not it's not going away
it's here and I think you know this this
new wrinkle what what it kind of
inspired me around thinking through is
ephemeral influencers right like you
know she might suddenly show up with you
know a cult right and suddenly have a
million people following and being there
the platform and it might go away and
that's okay
you know so it made me think of kind of
like the Andy Warhol quote of everyone's
gonna have 15 minutes of fame right I
think it's in this case everyone's gonna
have 15 million dollars right it's look
like she might make 15 million dollars
right and that's a life-changing amount
for her and her family but because she
was creative about something and she
basically created a new form factor
within other platforms a platform within
a platform and it might be ephemeral and
go away and that's okay yeah and it
feels like it's becoming more and more
obvious every day as the more redundant
kind of my new activities or getting
automated away and software's replacing
a lot of that work the creative side of
this is just getting exponentially more
valuable right and we're kind of seeing
that just explode and so something like
the step chickens cult which you know is
hilarious at lure the New York Times is
writing about it but they're writing
about it because it's real right and has
serious audience serious influence we'll
probably see a thousand more of those
over the coming years absolutely and
here's not just that but here's to
having a thousand you'ens bloom a
thousand Travis as a thousand Steve Jobs
and and you know I think I think that's
that that that all of it like everyone
should rise and anyone who wants to be
an entrepreneur has the opportunity to
do that and the only there's no
middleman left and all of the most
expensive parts of building these
components continue to drop over time
and I think we've learned a lot of
lessons over the last 10 years of
capital is not is not a guarantor of
success or scale just because you have a
billion dollars to spend doesn't mean
you have a billion dollars of scale
those are two very different things
I won't name names but we've seen a
couple of companies raise a lot of money
and and they don't go anywhere right
usually they raise that money before
they ever launch a product and so that
it's a can almost hurt you more right
then actually just building apart to
begin with before we wrap up I want to
talk about outside of tech investing
what else are you investing in or what
else are you excited about either before
kind of the corona virus pandemic or now
as we're seeing some of the economic
shocks like how are you thinking about
the rest of your portfolio or your
investing activities I we care a lot
about that as a family because we came
from nothing and you know we have to get
back and you know my children you know I
have two kids and they care a lot about
giving back as well and so does my my
nephews and niece and so we have them
all involved I'm lucky that my sister
Sarah is a head of the Family Foundation
to fish for our Family Foundation called
PI like P I and and then the we're
trying to bring the same kind of
systemic thinking but also you know
innovation to what we're doing so as an
example in this you know crisis and
pandemic early on I kind of latched on
to the idea of using 3d printers and
laser cutters to basically 3d print you
know mass face mass and and shields and
and and and so we kind of created a
movement to do that called health alas
and we partnered with IRA Foundation and
others and and we've now I think the
numbers like we've delivered like
something like 20,000 made and are
delivering 20,000 face shields to
hospitals here in in Florida in New York
in Mexico and in other places and we're
going to continue to scale that
and you know it was been a really cool
project and Sarah has been helping scale
that and those are the kinds of ideas we
like he also did something called the
Cyrus prize to kind of find you know
young Iranian Americans who are you know
incredibly smart and are working on big
ideas and you know giving out a hundred
thousand prize to them that's awesome
before I end I always ask the same two
questions everybody the first being
what's the most important book you've
ever read wow that's a great question
yeah that's like asking you to choose
your children I would I remember when I
read heart of darkness by Joseph Conrad
in my early teens it blew my mind I just
was like I just remember what an impact
it had same with old men in the sea
by Hemingway it just those are stories
that never leave you
stretch your minds so from a fiction
perspect that I picked you know one of
those if you were to make me pick one I
would say you know heart of darkness and
then in terms of nonfiction I would say
you know I read burn rate back in the
90s and it and it had a huge impact on
me and you know it always made me
remember that story and that cycle has
repeated itself so many times where
people have raised a lot of capital and
then forgot about their burn rate and
burned too much capital and ran out and
capital is your oxygen and talent as is
as well so you have to keep
those two things in in tandem in your
mind and get ahead of it because you run
out of both you're dead
yeah those are two great books and then
the last question we spoke a bunch of
about SpaceX but what about aliens
believer non-believer how do you kind of
think through whether there might be
intelligent life out there that's a
great that's a funny question you know
back to some conversations with veal on
earth in the early days I remember
talking to him well before everybody was
talking about simulations and I you know
and we would go back and forth on it and
you know one of the insights was I
remember saying like given almost
infinite time everything that could have
happened has already happened so we're
already living in the future and you
know from a scientific perspective I
think I think that's a and it's a even
weirder thing to say it and to say
aliens are are real but scientifically
it could work out and and what I mean by
that is that if you have highly advanced
AI and and some kind of merger between
biological life and AI if that's the
future right and if we're already living
in that future my insight was you know
that what would any advanced
intelligence want to answer and it's the
fundamental question when I was a kid
I'd look up at the sky and be like okay
everyone says God created just this
world well who created God and then I
would black out like that because that
was such a scary thought that there was
nothing and then there was something so
I was like look you know in advanced
intelligence would want to really
reverse engineer or history through
trillions of simulations and we might be
living in just one of those stacked up
against each other
and to them
it's a blink of an eye right and you
know the advanced intelligence would
want mutants would want people who
experiment who been who been the
universe because it's it's the mutants
and the different thinkers like like to
Steve Jobs or the Edison's and so on
who-who bend the fabric of the universe
and one of the things you know people
who have done that in our experiences
I've seen this universally when we try
to bend the universe the universe yields
right and so and it yields in the way
it's supposed to yield if you understand
that then it's a it's a core generator
of courage and allows you to not be
afraid it's the antidote to the fear of
taking risks because if the universe is
gonna yield if you try ultimately and
you fail and you keep trying and failing
and keep trying in the works in the end
like Edison's light bulbs he made 1,800
versions of it
so my long answer to you is yes but a
different kind of alien I love it and
look I think ultimately it goes back to
that unshackling of the mind right if
you're able to to do that it's
incredibly powerful if people want to
learn more about the work you're doing
or the investing you're doing where can
we send them to learn more they can go
to peshawar calm or sherman calm no my
first name or last name and there's some
info there and you know my email is just
my name Shervin official or calm awesome
listen thank you so much the next
johannes with Steve Jobs you know let me
know don't say that on the internet
you're gonna get a whole bunch of trolls
along with maybe one that might be real
you know obviously we can't answer every
every but but the swarming concept is a
good one like you know I emailed Travis
you didn't answer but you know if you
have people that I know like you that
vouch for you then the probability of
you know something happening and
engagement and learning more as is it's
gonna happen for sure bend the universe
I love it I love it
listen thank you so much for doing this
I think people will get a ton out of
this and I'll do it again in the future
I really love your approach and
framework of thinking